like only as well it's a real  dichotomous like people being like is it  female empowerment to make money off of  your body or is it disrespectful is it  and I'm very much a middle ground  people like choosing what they want to  choose but I just think we're not honest  with women about the consequences so  like even with Buddy who cares because I  don't care about the consequences  and be like people like do you care if  your family I don't give a [ __ ] about my  family it's totally fine like I'm I'm  all for empowered women to do what they  want to do like if you if you want to go  start your own fans go ahead say I'm not  gonna stop you go crazy like get that  bat butt but what I do think we do is  like lie to younger women and tell them  there's no consequences for that stuff